I mean I think the most important thing
to say about green architecture right
now is that it's becoming less and less
of a big deal not because we're not
doing it but because we are doing it in
other words I'm saying that to make the
point that we're not marginalizing it
it's becoming so central to the making
of architecture that I don't even know
that we have to talk about it so much
and one of the reasons is that we've
learned how to make traditional by
traditional I don't mean historical I
just mean regular buildings in a much
more energy efficient way than we used
to so the question about how will green
architecture change the appearance of
buildings may end up being answered by
saying not very much but not because
green architecture isn't happening it's
because we've learned to integrate it so
well that it doesn't change the
appearance as much as we thought I mean
an example might be glass years and
years ago when the first serious
attempts were made to make buildings
more energy-efficient people you say oh
well that's the end of glass buildings
because you know nothing's worse than
glass and that's that and we're going to
see you know lots of masonry buildings
again or lots of this if I said that in
fact we now have more glass buildings
than ever and that's because glass
itself has changed and manufacturers
have learned how to make glass into
what's almost a different material and
that it's much more energy efficient
than it was before it has it performs in
a way that's much closer to opaque
material to stone or something like that
not literally the same but closer than
it used to be and so we're seeing plenty
of glass buildings after all but they're
much more energy responsive they're much
more green than a generation ago so in a
way it's kind of like the situation with
cars you know
it's all well and good to talk about
hybrids and hybrids have been a
incredibly positive addition to the
roads let's say but what's less talked
about is how much more efficient
conventional engines have become so you
know you can buy a hybrid but you could
also buy a BMW or Audi that in fact gets
almost as good mileage through a much
more efficient conventional engine and
we're seeing that in architecture to an
awful lot of buildings that are just may
look like a different an older kind of
building but in fact are much more
efficient they don't necessarily have to
be totally different the way the hybrid
is totally different and of course even
within the realm of the hybrid you know
this the Prius which looks different or
then there's a hybrid engine inside a
Toyota Camry that looks the same so in
architecture too there's an analogy I
mean you can sort of the building can
express how green it is if the architect
and the client wanted to or it cannot
express that but still be just as green
jane jacobs and her ideas about the
nature of the city in about the city
being an organic living thing and the
thing capable of constant regeneration
and the street being so important those
have almost become the common wisdom
today they're not considered radical
quite the contrary they're considered
very mainstream almost now but as with
everything you know in every silver
lining there's a cloud you could say you
know there's a downside to even this
very good thing and that's that when
someone's ideas become mainstream
there's always the tendency of people
who are not so responsible to exploit
them so we do see real estate developers
today talking about you know how much
their projects enhance street life and
and presenting 70 story condos as
additions to the cityscape which as the
kind of things that jane jacobs would
have liked when in fact it's quite the
opposite they're not I thought the
ultimate of that was a few years ago
when me project the Jets project to do a
stadium on the west side of Manhattan
was being pushed and one of the
arguments made for the design was that
it would have tucked into the bottom
lots of little shops and restaurants and
things like that so that when there was
not a football game it would enliven the
cityscape well you know the notion of
using Jane Jacobs ideas about enlivening
the streetscape to justify an 80,000
seat football stadium in the middle of
Manhattan totally turn her notions on
their head and I do think we're seeing a
certain amount of that now or things
like you know urban festival
marketplaces faneuil hall and Boston and
all the progeny of that is a kind of
the commercial corruption of a lot of
what Jane Jacobs was arguing for but is
the glass half empty or is a glass
half-full you know is it if if you
compare a festival marketplace kind of
urban thing to a real city street with
all the energy and intensity and
heterogeneity of a true city street it
doesn't come off so well if you compare
it however to a suburban mall it looks
pretty good so you know is is the glass
half empty or as the glass half full
it's almost a question of what your
temperament is how you choose to read
that I I'd rather read it as a sign that
there is a kind of urban impulse in this
society which i think is good even if
that urban impulse sometimes plays out
in crass commercial ways